welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss and the most tragic night in star
wars history was reframed yet again on
the book of boba fett this time through
the eyes of poor grogu trauma peeped in
on by the son of the war criminal who
led the slaughter kind of like
accidentally clicking on the folder on
your dad's desktop labeled tax documents
oh papa what have you done but this new
dramatic imagery is filled with clues
helping us answer the long time mystery
of how exactly grogu escaped the jedi
temple an answer we were still deprived
of when grogu's memory faded to black
here so who saved grogu from order 66. i
did investigate this after the
mandalorian season 2 but now thanks to
this scene we can actually narrow it
down to two very interesting suspects
also you can join us in person to chat
about this stuff live in chicago this
friday february 11th at 8pm italia hall
rooster teeth's very normal podcast
store ticket link in the description
also to get your hands on our great boba
fett inspired shirt go to
newrockstarsmerch.com we're getting one
of these allows you to write in a custom
shout out for our after shows okay let's
review what asukitano first told us
about grogu on the night of order 66. he
was raised at the jedi temple on
coruscant many masters trained him over
the years at the end of the clone wars
when the empire rose to power he was
hidden someone took him from the temple
then his memory becomes
dark we can deduce from this that ahsoka
did not know any of this until after she
used the force to read grogu's memories
here despite ahsoka being only five
years younger than grogu when she was
younger training at the temple she did
not know grogu existed krogu was a
secret known only to a handful of jedi
masters and since anakin skywalker was
denied the rank of master in revenge of
the sith he probably did not know grogu
existed either and now this new
flashback shows that night from grogu's
perspective three unidentified jedi
fight the 501st clone trooper battalion
these are the best of the best nicknamed
vader's fist the two jedi on the side
are hooded we cannot determine who they
were there's one in the center with
blonde hair tied in a bun similar hair
to temple battle master syndralic but
this probably wasn't centralic he was
training older padawans at this exact
moment and holocron security footage
showed him dying instead against anakin
one-on-one nor is this figure librarian
jocasta knew this person is a man also
that night jocasta was found by anakin
in the archives she refused to light a
temple beacon that anakin wanted her to
do to lure other jedi into this death
trap so anakin killed her jocasta might
have been the jedi to initially hide
grogu but she could not have been the
one to escort him out of the temple now
we also don't know if these jedi or the
500 first were aware of grogu in the
corridor behind them because after the
jedi fall listen to those clone troopers
yeah that clone trooper doesn't say grab
that kid he just says keep moving as
ahsoka said grogu was hidden he may have
been hidden inside of something so that
the 500 first did not see him in this
moment now i have speculated that that
thing could be r2d2 who was present at
the temple during order 66 accompanying
anakin and argentina was with anakin
right after the temple when he went to
padme's home and r2 had some super
freaked out exchange with 3po
and considering grogu's size lines up
with r2 storage and r2's excited
greeting of this child as if they had
met before
[Music]
there might be some history between
these two now i get if you're getting
cold feet on that hot take completely
understandable what's unforgivable is
cold feet due to wet socks no one likes
wet socks they have zero approval rating
so to keep your toes warm and dry you
don't have to resort to wearing some big
clunky boots you can wear some sleek
comfortable vessy shoes thanks to bessie
for sponsoring this video besties are
the perfect everyday shoe they're
sustainably made knit sneakers that are
100 waterproof they keep your winter
feet dry and warm without any of the
clunkiness of boots and as a bonus they
are great in warm months too like me
these bad boys work all day every day
they are made with this great dimetex
material that's super easy to clean with
just a rinse of water whatever the
season messies are truly an everyday
shoe
oh no
i spilled water all over my feetsy
weezies but my oinky oinkies are bone
dry like the dune seed thanks bessie
banish those soggy socks forever that's
these are my go-to shoes by the door
check them out in the link below for a
pair of your very own vesty shoes now
this new scene confirms that grogu was
already hidden by the time the clone
troopers opened fire so it's not like
grogu by luck or by happenstance
remained hidden during the massacre and
then was discovered later no he was
there in the corridor when the action
was happening but obscured so this rules
out yoda and rules out obi-wan kenobi
from being the first jedi to find in a
hyde grogu obi-wan was on udapal yoda
was on kashyyyk it wasn't until the next
morning that they arrived at the temple
and at that point grogu would have
already been hidden and removed from the
temple now in the past we have brought
up yaddle as a possibility jedi master
who was on the jedi high council and
phantom menace and then left some time
after there was a legends story in which
seattle dies before order 66 a story no
longer canon technically and then a
comic darth vader number 25 showed
anakin slaying a forced projection of
yattle while trying to metaphorically
kill off his past but other than the
line in jedi fallen order speculating
what might have happened to master
seattle we don't know really what
happened to her after the scene many
have asked about that four diamond
symbol on the walls of the quarter and
grogu's flashback this does show up on
the temple walls when anakin confronts
barris in the investigation of the jedi
temple bombing in clone wars season 5
episode 20. in fact this location looks
like the same hallway where jedi
residences are barris who truly
committed the bombing that ahsoka was
framed for does have similar diamond
patterns tattooed on her face and was
last seen taken into custody when the
truth came out but those diamond
patterns were really just spiritual
markings on many of the walls of the
jedi temple it's not barris's symbol
specifically and really these tattoos
were later adopted by baris in the
fashion of her master luminara unduli
who has the same tattoos and luminara is
actually someone we should take a look
at here because she was also on kashyyyk
during order 66 like yoda and also
escaped she later returned in rebels we
thought as a prisoner of the inquisitors
but we learned had actually already been
executed years earlier and now her
remains were mummified and used as a
trap to lure in the jedi to the
inquisitors now since luminara was not
on coruscant during order 66 like yoda
and obi-wan she couldn't have been the
one to initially hide grogu but she is a
character that dave filoni seems super
interested in with several years of her
life currently left open a mystery now
if it was just one jedi master working
alone to save grogu someone near the
temple on the night someone who would
have known about grogu as i've suggested
before a very good suspect is mace windu
after anakin suffered his arm and
palpatine zapped him out the window we
never saw his body everyone wants him to
come back everyone's expecting him to
come back and this guy would have had
just enough time to limp over to the
jedi temple and secure this secret young
lady and i bring him up because recently
in interviews with imdb tamora morrison
and mignon win mention mace windu as a
figure boba fett still in the present
and future wants to seek revenge upon i
own big time
revenge a little bit i've got my eye on
him he's top of the list in fact slow
torture though i think we'd better let
john favreau know that we should have
another series and i start looking for
mace so will the boba fett finale be the
place mace windu returns to reveal his
survival that night or is filoni saving
that for the obi-wan kenobi series for
the mandalorian season 3 or ahsoka if
mace windu is alive revealing him as the
rescuer of grogu one arm will row
hooding whatever kim toto grogu was
hidden inside shoving out of the way the
other less cuddlable padawans that would
be the badass character return we've
been waiting for for this guy
alternatively if it wasn't just one jedi
who saved grogu this rescue mission
really could have been a three-step
handoff one jedi master to initially
hide him and again i love the idea of
this being inside of r2d2 but maybe
grogan was just stored inside of
something else and that first jedi
master being one of those three from the
flashback or jocasta new or yaddle if
she's still alive or just someone we
haven't met yet someone who did not make
it out of the temple alive but then step
two the container is transported
knowingly or knowingly out of the temple
kind of like the basket carrying baby
moses and then finally a receiver jedi
discovers grogu in this container and if
that container was r2 then it could have
been obi-wan or yoda when they all met
up on the asteroid polish masa this
handoff could have happened in the time
between padme giving birth to luke and
leia and r2 and 3po ending up in the
custody of baylor ghana but one would
think that if grogo ended up in obi
wan's hands or yoda's hands grogu would
have been far more protected but when we
first met grogu in the first episode of
the mandalorian he was in the hands of a
random nikto gang being hunted by moff
gideon's clients these imperial
loyalists so one would think that
instead he ended up in the custody of
someone who could not continue to look
after him someone who met an untimely
end perhaps that final jedi master
recipient being luminara
who met a tragic end when she was
arrested by inquisitors yet still
someone who could have played a fateful
role in securing the future of the jedi
or the future of the mandalorians
whoever grogu wants to celebrate his
life days with so mace windu working
alone or luminar and dooley working with
a network who do you think saved grogoo
after this latest flashback comment down
below and follow me on instagram and
twitter at e vos follow new rockstars
subscribe to rockstars for more analysis
of everything you love thanks for
watching bye
[Music]
you